gosh there's so many things that led to
me asking can i
can i try to do an action movie um and
one of them was
i had all these intense feelings inside
me from these
uh break-ins that my actual family had
here in los angeles
so you had a home invasion while you
were in the house
i basically did what you know the movie
the way the movie starts you know i
kept it to a minimum uh the damage to a
minimum which is to say not
engage with this person um
but you can't help but feel like you
could have done more you should have
done
more and uh of course most these guys
who train you
when i do you do can't help but after a
while i ask them what would you do what
would you do
what do you do for your attack they all
say run get out of there
bob how hard is it for a 58 year old guy
to really go into the gym every day and
get into some kind of physical condition
where people will believe that you could
be an
action star 58 yeah there was a lot of
embarrassment and potential
embarrassment involved
i mean the hardest part was not the
hours just doing the same movement
over and over it was feeling like
a fool uh is like being in the corner of
the gym
going what the hell is wrong with me
there's no way i'll ever get there
and also surrounded by the best stunt
actors in the world because that's
what's happening at this gym
and and keanu's training with his team
for john wick and statham comes walking
through and says hi to you
and you're like i'm look at that guy
look at me i know
halle berry's there training being
amazing and
invisible and dancing around and
flipping
and you're like in the corner sucking
and going and you can see
because there's freaking mirrors giant
walls of mirrors
to show you how bad you are but after a
year and a half of training
daniel bernhardt this trainer uh you've
seen him in atomic blonde he's an
incredible stunt actor uh finally was
the first time he told me
you got to slow down your movements so
when i heard that i i figured i was
making some progress
but i had two and a half years of
training before we
hit the screen well it paid off because
you talk about this bus scene there's a
scene where bob
is on a bus with these group of young
guys who are [ __ ]
and uh bob's going to teach him a lesson
and you know just fight him
you know hand-to-hand combat and it is
it's a very bloody scene and it's good
because bob gets screwed up too it's not
like he walks out of there unscathed
i mean right from the start that was
part of it howard as i said uh
first thing i want to do is i want to
get hurt so it's like a real dad
when you try to do anything the first
thing you do is you hit your [ __ ]
head
on a bar or something yeah they're going
to want a sequel
would you do one thinking i was like
it's set up for a sequel this would be
great to come back are you going to do
it or is it like a [ __ ] this
i mean oh you want to do it no no no i i
continue to train
uh i mean listen i'm writing a comedy
piece with my friend david cross and
i'm writing a bunch of different things
but i would happily and excitedly do
more action you can see bob odenkirk
starring in nobody which is in theaters
now and is available on demand
april 16th by the way do you have abs
now do you have a six pack
as they call it i have a four pack nice
i'm leaving what happened to the other
two ice cream
ice cream ice cream